como cada día estos dos defensores del
medio ambiente van a bucear en el océano
para observar su estado en la costa de
kenia
82% del arrecife de coral está muy
dañado
este coral es muy diferente de los
corales vivos cuando está en buena salud
está lleno de colores
aquí está el futuro de los recursos para
la pesca y el futuro de las especies
marinas y según la dinámica que estamos
viendo en este momento para el 2050
vamos a tener grandes problemas
los pescadores fueron los primeros
testigos del daño causado a los corales
en 2003 fundaron una asociación para
intentar preservar los peces en la playa
dixon les enseña a los jóvenes y les
muestra la importancia de la protección
del océano en esta época casi no
pescamos nada en comparación con antes
entonces nos preguntamos cómo reactivar
la actividad pesquera y las poblaciones
de peces en esta zona entendimos que
había que dejar que las poblaciones de
peces se renovarán
para él es importante formar a estos
jóvenes que representan el futuro del
océano aquí la asociación options and
life impulsó la creación de una reserva
marina gestionada por los habitantes del
pueblo desde 2019 construye arrecifes
artificiales después se depositan en el
agua y se usan para hacer crecer los
corales
el objetivo de este jardín de corales es
transformar esta área en una zona de
reproducción
sirve también para hacer que la gente
entienda mostrarles que no tenemos que
ser espectadores de estos eventos que
podemos actuar para proteger lo que es
querido para nosotros
hasta hoy han sembrado alrededor de
3.600 colonias de coral es un primer
paso en el futuro el edema espera que
toda la costa de kenia tenga un arrecife
de corales en perfecto estado